a natural force of nature unlike any
other El Nino is capable of unleashing a
fury of climate changes and natural
disasters that span from Alaska all the
way to South America and beyond what
causes El Nino and how are we affected
by it El Nino is not a storm but rather
a weather phenomenon in the Pacific
Ocean during an El Nino the surface
water temperature warms up leading to
complex weather patterns South American
fishermen in the 19th century describing
warmer waters during Christmas time
coined the name El Nino Spanish for the
Blessed child nowadays when sea surface
temperatures in the equatorial Pacific
Ocean rise point 5 degrees Celsius over
their historic average for three
consecutive months and once atmospheric
conditions and rainfall patterns shift
accordingly
scientists officially declare an El Nino
an El Nino event takes place about every
two to seven years normal east to west
trade winds over the Pacific weaken and
warm water that normally travels
westward is now moving toward the east
moisture then rises into the air and the
effects of El Nino are felt throughout
the Americas in the ocean warm water
pushes colder water downward blocking
the important upwelling of nutrient-rich
waters from the bottom this causes some
marine life to migrate to colder waters
animals that normally feed on the sea
life suffer and Fisheries throughout
Central and South America suffer too but
El Ninos most noticeable repercussions
are felt on land
in the western United States and Central
and South America the warm air and
moisture lead to increased storms
rainfall floods loss of life and
property and the increase of some vector
borne diseases like malaria even in
places where they don't normally occur
in Southeast Asia and Australia the
opposite takes place these areas suffer
from droughts wildfires and colder ocean
waters in 1997 and 98 the world
experienced the biggest El Nino in
recorded history
some estimates blame that el nino for
2100 deaths and 33 billion dollars in
damages mongolia saw temperatures reach
108 degrees fahrenheit there was record
flooding in peru and the u.s. saw storms
in the Gulf Coast
flash flooding from California to
Mississippi and tornadoes in Florida
scientists are now better able to
predict if and when an El Nino event
will take place this helps communities
better prepare for the changes in
weather patterns and better adapt to its
repercussions